New York Post has a story here a Georgia
high school football coach was fired
after he held a baptism service for 20
of his players on school grounds last
month according to a report the
superintendent of tatol County High
School announced coach Isaac Ferrell's
firing after a video uploaded to the
team's official Facebook page showed
players being baptized in a tub by a
local Pastor footage shows Pastor Gary
Fu directing players individually to sit
in a large black tub of water before
saying to them I baptize you now my
brother in the name of the Father the
Son and the Holy Spirit Pastor then
ducts their heads under the water all
surrounding players cheer and support
but the incident outraged some community
members eventually leading one to inform
a group called the freedom from religion
foundation and uh that Foundation then
went after the school and now the coach
has been fired though I believe he still
has um his teaching job but he's been
fired from uh from his coaching position